le ring leur avait manqué après près de
quatre mois d'arrêt suite à la crise
sanitaire la pratique des sports de
combat est de nouveau autorisée en
france depuis le 11 juillet un
soulagement pour ses boxeurs
professionnels de la team farrugia
elancourt on a eu toute la salle
attendait ça on annoncera et tous les
jours je recevais des coups de téléphone
ou des textos
alors demain c'est ouvert qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand c'est que je boxe alors
assez compliquée depuis l'annnonce les
boxeurs s'entraîne avec contacts dans
cette salle du palais des sports à
elancourt pour eux cette reprise est
logique
je comprends et je comprends que ça a
été tardive puisque brossé on est dans
une situation sanitaire qu'on n'avait
pas connu avant maintenant est ce que je
comprends qu'à la reprise on est
totalement puisque on est plus en
confinement des mesures ont été prises
il ya des gestes barrières que tout le
monde respecte enfin la plupart des gens
en tout cas donc moi je comprends que
les sports reprennent dans le monde
amateur les sports de combats ont repris
plus tôt depuis le 22 juin dernier les
boxeurs peuvent venir pratiquer leur
passion dans cette salle de sport de
monti le bo tenu 5 soulagement moi
j'avais besoin j'étais un peu enfermé je
bouillonnais un peu et elle a box moi ça
m'aide à
après sortir un peu tout ouïe contente
parce que voir avec le confinement on
est content de pouvoir se défait de
zorro de défouler un de se défouler le
soir on malgré que je faisais un peu de
sport à la maison mais c'est quand même
pas pareil à l'ambiance il ya voilà les
coaches sont là pour vous pour vous
pousser un petit peu aussi dans l'effort
donc c'est quand même vachement plus
sympa
au total une trentaine de sportifs
viennent dans cet espace chaque jour
pour répondre au problème est lié à
l'épidémie les courants dû être adapté
on essaye de bien évidemment changer un
petit peu la pratique où ça va être
beaucoup plus de shadow c'est-à-dire de
mouvements de mime de boxe on va faire
des ateliers mais sans contact de
préférence des échauffements t-box n'est
en effet beaucoup moins de contact et
essayer de respecter la dispensation
social au maximum prochaine étape pour
la boxe la reprise en compétition les
premiers galas sont programmées pour la
fin du mois de juillet en france